for everyone hello I am your speaker
right before lunch my name is Daniel I
am still a PhD student for as I told
Jared that this conference is pretty
much a running tally of how long I've
been in grad school so I mean instructor
data scientists a community member
around the DC and New York areas I'm
also in about a couple of weeks going to
be one of the interns for our studio and
also like Aris ed wrote this thing and
some other language that's not this
conference but so I like in the DC area
I get a lot of flack for attending all
these are calm for meetings and then all
of a sudden like giving away a book
about Python so PyCon was last week and
so I wore my and my R shirt in front of
the giant Stadium just to like make it
fair I guess something else I did so we
Hugh and I also started in our package
during Python I also if anyone uses
ansible submitted a pull request the
ansible to help build our packages and
ansible so I was pretty productive doing
our things at the pipe Python conference
last week like Jared said I am I just
got my cave certification so this is
very recent and I get to dawn on life
support equipment and go into deep dark
holes and on the role of mental health
this is sort of like one of the few
things that I found that I can totally
check out of the world and so I am also
working on being a instructor so I can
help other people do other things to
detach themselves from daily chaos so
this talk is really a continuation from
the talk I gave around at DC up a couple
months ago there's a link to it but
pretty much the problem they were
solving then is structuring your data
science projects right so we're happy
when our card our code just runs our
gives us a bunch of tools to make this
happen so
we saw from Emily's talk about how do we
can easily make packages Jared showed
about the here package to help finding
paths easier and if you really think
about this problem all the little
problems you have when you're working
with projects or analysis pipelines a
lot of people end up converging to the
same exact problem our solution
so Jenny Brian has a talk about this or
a book tour manual about this John bliss
check actually wrote a entire r package
called workflow R that pretty much sets
up project templates for you guys so
people converge to the same solution and
my point back then and it still holds
true right now is it doesn't matter
where you are in your learning path
there's always some other thing to make
life easier right and so at the end of
the day I just want stuff to run the
first time around I don't want to like
mess around with project paths I just
want to run my code and then be done
with it so this is sort of like the
summary from last time you know there's
different steps in your our journey so
the first step is okay this isn't our
conference so we'll use our and then if
you have problems with working directory
stuff then at a project write just layer
up complexity until you get used to it
then go to the next layer and then
you'll end up like with knitter and
other things like okay knitter doesn't
really respect where my working
directory is when I knit projects what
do I do with that so we have this here
function from the here package that
comes from a library called our project
and then that's great we have our whole
knitter document but then you end up
with this problem with like sometimes
your scripts are like 500 lines long or
your documents are like a thousand lines
long and then you realize okay maybe I
should break this up into multiple files
right so the analysis thing is separate
from the data cleaning thing for example
and then what you want to do this was
something that got put into words better
than I can by Rachel Chapman she's one
of the data science advocates at cattle
in Seattle and pretty much what you want
to do is really use our markdown for the
thing that you want to show right
there's no point putting entire data
cleaning pipeline in an R markdown
document just make it an R script and
the our markdown file should really just
be hey here are my results great this is
the thing you want to show up to the
meeting Emily showed how easily you can
make it our package so when you start
making your analysis gets bigger one of
the key things and making our packages
may put all your functions in the
capital our folder so if you start doing
that in your analysis project and what
you really need is just that one
description file that you can add
anytime later on and then your entire
analysis can be installed as an r
package right so it's just about adding
little things just to set yourself up
for the next piece and then you can
start using make files and shell scripts
just build everything in one go right so
where did we originally start there was
a billboard data set and the script had
everything in it
so hopefully this works so this is the
example script that I had right I'm
setting a working directory don't do
this and this is actually if you go to
the tidy data paper this was Hadleys
original code before deep wire right you
can also see like there is no slicing
notation this goes from X to the 76 I
think that's where that goes then we go
through a step of tidying data sets
right this is something that you could
do you might think about how your data
is going to be stored so there's a
normalization section you'll also notice
that in our studio if you do this hash
and then the word and then five dashes
it'll start creating sections that you
can jump to in our studio and then we go
through exploratory data analysis so
there's stuff there and then at the end
we might fit a model and at the very end
we might ask them questions right and
this is pretty simple and it's already a
hundred and seventy lines right so when
I say like break this thing up
I almost I started this process of
almost never using this section break in
our studio because most of the time that
should just be a separate file and I
just write out files and read back files
in and out that way all right
so this talk is really about
reproducibility and replicability so
reproducibility if I'm going to define
it is extent which consistent results
are obtained when the experiment is
repeated versus the actual experiment
being done again through another system
right so like there's a difference
between like hey I want this thing to be
to run on my computer and if I hit go
again it gives me the same result versus
hey I am giving you my the process that
I have and I want you to rerun the
experiment with your data and see if the
results match right this is a common
problem that we have in science and so
if I look at my project here's like an
example folder that we have we have an
analysis folder and I have all of my
scripts that somehow it didn't get
sorted but you say that not everything's
in our markdown file the only thing in
here is a model and my EDA and
everything is a regular script I have my
make file to make everything and then
there's just bunch of output that's
either the report or like an image or
something else and then there's a folder
called original under data that is the
data set that I got in and I never
change it because everything else goes
into a folder called processed right and
this way like I can I can know if I
delete everything in process there's
some system to build everything back so
how do we run scripts from the command
line we can run our script and then the
name or path to the script that we want
to run and if you end up using here in
our prod what's nice is if you instead
of just putting dot dot slash or just
the name of the file in your our script
if you use here because it's gonna find
the absolute path to your data set
wherever you are and it's based off the
art project you can like save yourself a
lot of typing and you don't have to type
all of this you can really just type go
CD into the zero-one the folder where 0
1 load R is and just run it straight
there right so it'll save you a lot of
typing in that sense because it will
find the working directory or find the
correct file for you anyway and if you
want to run something in the background
this is assuming you're on like a unix
linux system you can no help this
ripped back round it so you can continue
other parts so the no hop thing is
pretty cool if you're using our studio
1.2 there's a new jobs panel in the top
in one of the corners and that sort of
lets you do the back rounding story in
our studio so you don't have to like
remember that weird terminal command you
can put in your our script here you can
even set your working directory and then
you can hit start and then your job just
runs and the problem and the nice thing
about that is when you're in our studio
you'll remember if you hit like source
or whatever the entire session locks up
you can't just keep working again and so
that's why breaking up your scripts into
different pieces is really useful
because you can just say hey this thing
is gonna run in the backgrounds and
clean my data and I can just work on the
next portion of my script and about you
go
what about build scripts so I have
everything and I just want to rerun my
analysis so this is where may comes in
so make has things called tasks there is
a target file by colon and in all of its
dependencies they're separated by space
make is really antiquated and sometimes
this part shows there are different
actions so like this defines all the
commands you need to do to make that
target and those actions for example
like running our script command have to
be a has to be a tab not four spaces
essentially has to be a backslash T and
then you just state which commands you
want to run so I know we're in our
conference but I'm really here to teach
you make and so you can make a really
simple make file it supports variable so
billboards here I'm using defining all
and commands and all it's doing is
looking for these two hashes so when I
say make for example it will print me
what I state in these comments so this
is a self documenting make file and so
the easiest thing you can do is just say
hey when I say make billboard eda just
run my entire pipeline right so this is
just gonna run all of those scripts in
that order etc etc and I can also make
like a clean file or a clink man and it
just deletes all of the files that I
know that got generated so if I want to
like redo my analysis I can just say
make clean everything that I know gets
that god generated is
and then I can just rerun the entire
pipeline again so when I say break up
your script into different parts this is
really what I mean and like I do stuff
like this when I'm documenting projects
for work I have a file and then all the
inputs that go into that file right so
this is sort of like in one of the
projects that I had at work this was
like a table in the readme right so for
each script I had I listed all of the
file inputs and then as another column
and I this is really in one table but
for I can't show that on the screen you
also list what are the outputs for each
file all right so really what I'm doing
is like for each script I write out some
file and in the next script I've read it
back in this could also be written to a
database whatever but if we really think
about it
so this is stuff I actually do when I
start making make files it's like draw
this out right like don't rely on just
staring at screens and stuff on the
screen because drawing things out like I
just hardened and they get workshop
yesterday
it really helps slow you down and like
makes you think about what's going on so
I have all of my file inputs and the
scripts to run each one of these right
and that comes in handy because
sometimes certain inputs for a certain
script generate multiple outputs so the
problem that we have sorry the problem
that we have is if I just run the entire
pipeline and one of those steps takes
like 30 minutes
if I run make pipeline for example it's
always going to take at least 30 minutes
right so sometimes if I edit the last
file that prints like one simple plot
like there's no need to wait 30 minutes
and so that's what make is actually
doing is this capturing this dependency
tree and only has to rerun the portions
that need to be run and that's also that
why I started to break my code into
pieces because if this thing took 30
minutes I do not want to accidentally
rerun this code again unless I
absolutely have to so let's make our
build script a little better so we can
add a few more variables that just helps
us with the saving to all the various
outputs that our script is going to go
to and
we can make here's the tiny section of
our script right so I have all of these
other scripts and then this is all of
the code ever that has to do with making
the data tidy you'll notice and make
there's a something called a phony
variable and so because a target has to
be a file when your target is not a file
you sort of make this a phony variable
and I'm sorry I'm pretty much saying
that when I say tidy these are all the
files that need to be checked to see if
they're up to date when I say tidy and
then for each one of these files for
example billboard songs and rank there
will be listed to the left hand side of
this colon and to the right hand side
that's all of the inputs right so that's
why when I said like draw everything out
is because you actually need to capture
what are your inputs also remember
you'll notice for example in this case
that the script that's used to generate
the target is also an input right you
don't want like just because your data
changes you rerun your targets if your
script updates to or you make changes
you actually really want to rerun that
pipeline as well and then we can do the
same thing for the EDA portion so I'm
making a phony a variable called EDA
these are the two things targets or that
relate to EDA and we need the actual
target is this EDA HTML it relies on the
are markdown file and then through
generate that HTML I run this render
command from the our markdown package
and then I can do the same thing for a
model so this model comes from this tidy
CSV to generate this model dot HTML and
you can sort of I guess I didn't
copy/paste it but then there's also the
command to rebuild that that model
target as well and then if you want you
can just say hey every time I make a TA
a model just I want them always run at
the same time so you can make another
phony variable called reports that just
links to the HTML for EDA and model and
then I can just make something that's
like let's just run the whole thing
that's tidy and reports and those
targets are going to be
for tidy and reports and the whole point
is like I can either say make reports or
make tidy and reports and I'll just
build the whole thing or only parts that
need to get updated right and then so
what I will do in my command line will
say make point it to my make file so
this is called make file - I can clean
it so all of my output is deleted and
then if I want to run the entire
analysis I can say make file tidy and
reports and then for example if I delete
a file or change a file it'll only
update that last bit right so I think we
have enough time for me to show this so
all right so here is make it clean right
and then you'll see when I make clean
all of the folders in here all of the
files in there got deleted and then I
can say make tidy and reports and you'll
see if you sort of squint your eyes it's
running through each one of those
scripts and then right now it's running
knitter for those two knitter documents
and it's creating those outputs I
believe if I start refreshing or looking
in here you'll see though those plots
are being generated all right
so let me go to output one more time in
reports so let's say I delete this file
the model HTML file and I run I you
reports again you'll see that the first
thing that gets run is just some
knitting function right so all those
other scripts because they never changed
don't need to be run again all right all
right so this isn't our conference
there's this thing called Drake what am
I not talking about Drake well it is
something just like make if something
doesn't need to be updated it won't run
there's a manual here and there's
documentation here you could potentially
do what I just said in our but it's not
exactly like make Drake has this notion
of a plan which is very similar to how
make finds targets and dependencies and
actions so there is like a target which
is an
our object but the problem that I end up
having is like the command has to be an
expression like an arc expression so
everything has to be a function and so
this is what a Drake plan looks like
this is taken from the documentation you
have something called raw data that's
just a variable and you have this
special Drake function called file
underscore in right and this is how
Drake is building that dependency tree
right like just like how I drew up that
thing file in a saying this is a file
input and this raw data is now the input
for this mutate function and it's called
data and then whoops data here is now
the input for the next piece which is
called hist and all of that eventually
feeds into this meter report and because
data frames are such a fundamental piece
of the our language you get a Drake plan
that's really a data frame that you can
kind of analyze that tells you for a
given target this is the expression
that's great
but that doesn't really work with if you
break up your skirt into individual
scripts for example if I'm just saying
scores source this file source this file
source that file the problem is there's
no way to link what the inputs are right
so that's the problem I'm having when I
work with Drake everything has to be
sort of in our function and all of this
stuff really has to like be loaded in
memory and there's temporary output
files that that get placed in your
directory so I can't personally use this
if I really wanted to have to rewrite
all my scripts I can patch it like patch
my scripts I rapping everything in a
function sort of defining inputs that
way to make this work with Drake but you
know I'm not here to complain as other
open-source maintainer so no complaining
isn't really helpful so during the
summer I'm working on this project
called great R that really tries to
automatically grade students code so
giving us a piece of solution code and
some piece of code that you're
submitting not to just be like hey your
answer is wrong but try to figure out
like why your answer is wrong like maybe
you should have used gather instead of
spread for example and the reason for
that well how does that fit into Drake
well so I really want to say given a
script find me like the file inputs and
file outputs right
I'll be one step to making Drake a
little bit closer to how I work by you
know like
extracting those automatically and it's
more than just string extraction and
essentially I know my times up but the
way I plan on doing this is looking at
something that had Lee talked about last
year called apps that abstract syntax
trees where you can just break up a
function call into its individual
components and that's how I plan on
finding your file inputs and hopefully
we can find input outputs of files and
then fold that eventually into Drake so
will I'm sorry I know I'm complaining
but hopefully I'm doing something about
it and that's my talk
[Applause]